hey reject nation its Greg Alba here I'm
John we are going to be watching a video
that was sent over to us called the
psychology of the Joker the dark night
edition of the Joker
hence the dark night shirt and funny
that we got this request to us because
we have a new sponsor today who I am so
grateful to be sponsored with right now
today's sponsor is better help calm and
we hope to be having an ongoing
partnership with them because this is
the exact kind of brand we would want
sponsoring the channel if you guys are
loyal followers of this channel you
would know that John and I both go to
therapy and I'm not afraid to get canned
and sometime especially we've seen our
film therapy segment that we recently
posted here on the channel
he's been going for many years I've been
going for several years and around the
time I started going to therapy I was
diagnosed with ADHD type 2 bipolar and
PTSD I was on many medications for years
whilst going to therapy and eventually
was able to get off all my meds through
meditation exercise and what all started
with therapy and it's funny that we live
in LA where therapy doesn't seem to have
as much of a stigma seeking to improve
your mental health but I know in other
parts of the world other parts of the
u.s. even there's still a stigma
surrounding bettering your mental health
and we always encourage people to go out
there and do what you can to go get some
therapy because I'm telling you guys
it's life-changing we wouldn't be here
today if it wasn't for therapy and the
thing though is that sometimes it can be
challenging to make the time to go to
therapy but even have the money to
afford therapy sessions and whatnot so
better help calm is a leading provider
of online therapy I have a friend
actually attends online therapy and
they've experienced a lot of benefits
from it as well so we're more than happy
to shop these guys out in this video
essentially what happens when you sign
up on the site you'll take a little
questionnaire that basically gives them
a sense for your needs and then within
about a 24 hour window better help calm
will pair you with a counselor or a
qualified to help you out with those
needs and you can meet with your
counselor via phone call video chat
messaging live text chat and also if you
need financial aid there are options for
you so yeah we looked into what the
average prices are and
they're pretty affordable definitely
cheaper that would hikers who spend to
go to therefore you might though yeah
there's several reasons why I think
online therapy is even a great start if
you're planning on eventually going to
therapy in person because it can you
don't have scary open you can be scary a
few feet away from you yeah so you could
do it you know video chat phone
messaging live text chat they have
almost 2,000 therapists you guys might
have heard of them already from people
like Philip DeFranco wisecrack a lot of
people talk about them because they are
truly a great company and we're so happy
that they're willing to sponsor this
video you can go click on the link in
the description box if taking some
therapy online is something you're
currently interested in so go check it
out link in the description box and
we're gonna talk about the psychology of
the Joker today someone who could
definitely use all either for attention
are all compulsions that can lead a
human being into a life of crime
you into unlock his secrets requires the
journey into the ultimate heart of
darkness
yeah be so cool that was an alternate
take in the trailer the evildoers in
Batman's universe is more explosive or
unpredictable known simply as the Joker
randomness the idea of the character of
the Joker just the luck of the carts
here's my card
alternate XE comics in 1940 the Joker
initially had no backstory over the
years separate issues of history
describing the characters maniacal
metamorphosis yes involves a tragedy in
which the Joker fell into a vat of
chemicals and became disfigured as a
result the action painting has changed
his appearance
twisted his mind you don't know what
makes him tick
maybe he won't kill you maybe you'll
hand you $1,000 bill he'll probably kill
you but you can't be sure
so in that way he's a perfect villain
for Batman most characters could justify
the terrible things they do as I'm doing
this for my family I'm doing this
because the world hates me of doing this
because pick an answer
the Joker doesn't goes I miss nothing
it's a squirrel and I proud of that
looking for anything logical they can't
be bought bullied recent wanna go
shocked it was evening just want to
watch the wallet but we set aside our
watch let's get our I've anxieties are
motivated by desire to gain greater
wealth or gain greater power to exact
revenge
there's a clear motivation which is
understandable for what's prompting
their behavior in the case of somebody
who's mentally ill you can't necessarily
predict what they're gonna do because
their motivations are not the normal
ones
- for example an individual such as John
Hinckley believed amidst his psychosis
and narcissism that if he were to
assassinate the President of the United
States Jodie Foster would fall in love
with him
you see quickly where the logic in that
line of thought Falls does not work he's
a unique necessarily after money or
power any of those traditional things so
that's really the hardest kind of evil
to fight because you can't bargain with
it in the Dark Knight and the Joker is
taken to the ultimate level
I like that there was a great curiosity
about this Joker because he hadn't come
across anybody like him before this is
another character like himself who will
not compromise whatsoever well I think
the Joker is the the logical response to
a character like Batman partly because
Batman having raised this extremity of
behavior and dolphinese putting on a
mask tapping into people's fears and
there's all of the technology he employs
he's distinguishing himself to fight
crime they're both men who operate
outside of normal social norms they're
both highly talented highly gifted at
what they do
yeah so they have a lot in common okay
every game has a yang every one of them
has a negative that means the Saiyan and
logical uses his mind to self problems
and self crimes and the Joker is to
complete reading lunatic
Batman says philosophically we can
acknowledge an imperfect world we can
acknowledge it we have to step outside
of social norms but that doesn't make
the social norms meaningless the Joker
says the presence of random injustice
means that there is no justice I like
that now when someone says your life is
a joke challenge Batman can't let go
because they're just threatening and
physically he's serving the premise of
Batman's existence that's why it's such
an epic design that they're having and
of course it's played out physically
it's play out in fights and punches and
gunshots
think Batman and Joker need to have a
debate at the town of philosophical
conflict not one that easily resolving
the Joker wants to see that everybody
has a price that nobody is pure
and even Batman
can be bought or can be leveraged in
such a way that he would compromise his
principles good evening ladies and
gentlemen
Heath was somebody I'd met with over the
years but four different rules indeed
I'd met him for Batman sometimes and you
know every actor in town explained Amy
he didn't want to do something like that
he was very polite about it but very
clear that's how I was sort of surprised
to get the call because it really more
came from isn't about wanting to get
involved wanting to talk to me about
what would be doing i sat down with him
for a couple of hours there's nothing
for him to read but we saw absolutely
eye-to-eye on the bigger picture idea of
who this guy was going to be we talked
about common reference points we talked
about
Malcolm a gallon fullest of Clockwork
Orange in the film we talk about culprit
Ronald the book and who Alex is in the
book is kind of different
we looked at paintings by fries bacon
the visual reference looked at all kinds
of things talked about kinds of
different philosophical ideas behind the
Joker panicking I've never seen
behind-the-scenes footage went through
the process of deal-making and
announcing it or anything I think the
whole world what he did you know Heath
Ledger Joker didn't make any sense to
people at all we didn't have that moment
here we just sort of you know made him
dress up as the Joker and suddenly the
Joker that would have real fischels so
he developed the look of the character
with linear having a costume design
every John Calley who need to make up
and myself over a long period of time so
we would experiment our I think of it
you know what would the shoes be I think
the shoes really the first thing that
when you found that he's like those are
typically right shoes like an amalgam of
shirts and ties but a Jack eNOS and
these are his color you know different
colors kind of safely going towards a
really black purple and they're thinking
no we got to do it
was to apply makeup himself this
character would put his own makeup on
you know in real life so what would that
provide if you just got makeup always
had makeup on his fingers and under his
fingernails and everything else he would
have from from putting it on just was
[Music]
character and use it as a bit of a test
bit just sort of do it in front of a few
people and start dealing well that would
be and move around
we had some props though head for dyeing
some things from the boys [ __ ] oh gosh
there's a really really amazing
experience to to be a part of the scene
developing some interest whoa damn the
video just end there whoa random a rep
ending that is yeah that was a really
interesting video in the way so it's not
cuz the first half of it was about
Batman vs Joker and what makes this
rivalry so impactful and Sam during yeah
cuz the Joker is like one of the biggest
villain characters of all time
yeah terms of our current consciousness
they're deconstructing what the rivalry
me cuz we've always loved the rivalry
but really I like how they were breaking
it down and this is more of a
philosophical battle amongst anything
else you know you made a joke about just
watching them like they need to have a
debate think them and Joker need to have
a debate but my favorite scene in the
Dark Knight is when they're debating
they're in the interrogation room it's
such a riveting scene I forget what
channel did this I think it's a channel
but they basically did you know script
to scene so they have the script playing
on the side while you're watching the
scene play out and it's amazing watching
Heath Ledger own those lines to the
point where it sounds like these are
improvised even to a guy like me
that's cold like oh these are all
scripted it just sounds like he's heard
it coming up it something spot yeah and
I like how the last half of this video
was pretty much some behind-the-scenes
process of Heath Ledger and what he did
to embody the Joker like I've never seen
it behind the scenes anything of the
Joker I kind of like never bother to
look it up honestly I've seen that one
scene where the tape continues after the
bus rolls away from the hospital a
little bit but other than that I've seen
like alternate everything like takes but
I haven't seen additional yeah that's
right he's just acting he's being
directed and everything it's just a
little moment when it's like the green
screen in the background and he's just
having a conversation when Nolan like
you can't hear it but watching him not
be in character you could tell he's just
Heath Ledger at that moment having a
discussion with him about what they
should do in the scene yeah a little
historic nugget right there and I do
appreciate the two halves of this video
and especially going into the psychology
kind of on two levels like the actor
approaching the character and then
actually getting really involved with
the costuming and the makeup to this is
not something every actor does or is
even expected to do we give Heath Ledger
a lot of credit for that performance and
I think he does deserve it cuz you know
there's this stuff that's on the page
there's the stuff that Nolan came up
with and all but you really get the
sense that he was heavily involved with
making this version of the Joker be a
lie he practically created the design
himself yeah it's crazy scene like the
different variations they could have had
which one they could have gone with and
to hear how he put the makeup on himself
and I've never noticed the Nugget
they're talking about of having a makeup
on his fingers we're gonna go watch it
again on IMAX really sound like I'm
gonna look at his fingers all the time
yeah ooh when he's in the interrogation
room I'm gonna be looking at his hands
oh boy is there makeup on his fingertips
okay I'm gonna just look out for those
kind of details and to know how involved
he was with a costume design and take
different knives to every little detail
was so important and I wasn't expecting
any of this behind-the-scenes stuff of
Heath Ledger going in and becoming the
Joker's I couldn't
any interviews on what he wanted to ever
deal with the only thing I've ever
looked up yeah he was pretty put it
close to the chest on this one I'm
playing this one pretty close to the
chest I feel like the second half of
this video is maybe more substantial
than the first half but I do just
appreciate the archetypes of the Joker
and Batman and what the Joker represents
in a philosophical form because yeah
like so many villains have motivations
that you can pick apart and the Joker
does seem like one of a few that really
is just a philosophical question mark
there's nothing you can do it through to
this and what do you do in the face of
that is true justice that works a
hundred percent of the time even
possible with a person or a character
like that I like how they're bringing up
the question of mental illness mmm
better help calm ha ha ha they bring up
the question of mental illness because
the portrayals of the Joker
I think if done correctly whether it be
from Mark Hamill or reading a comic or
the killing joke or watching Heath
Ledger you do wonder is he really
mentally ill you know or is he just so
down this particular philosophical
rabbit hold that he doesn't really care
about much else yeah yeah exactly
because he seems to understand his
perspective in his point of view he
seems very intelligent up the
differences of a guy who would shoot
Reagan to get Jodie Foster's love as
opposed to your like the Joker who seems
to know why he does what he does and
what the people around him you'd
probably do in response
yeah he could predict the outcome and
the responses of a normal person so it
makes you wonder is he really mentally
ill when in the Dark Knight there's even
that moment where he's in with the
police in the procession and you can
tell at least for a little while he can
blend in if he has to you know he can
mimic a regular person I mean is that be
a sociopath but you know mental illness
is abroad so yeah that's a very
different thing you know yeah I don't
think the Joker is a character you could
necessarily that's what they carry has a
variation of mental illness for sure
there's no denying that well I'm saying
is there seems to be like actual sound
logic and reasoning behind what he's
doing with how aware he is amazing and
usually with the case of mental illness
so extreme their awareness levels not
quite up to par yeah
yeah and going back to like the early
renditions of the Joker how they were
talking about how there was no backstory
and then eventually backstory was
introduced it makes me wonder if the
evolution of the Batman and the Joker
kind of came naturally in terms of how
well they complement each other because
it sounds to me like the Joker was
originally introduced it's just a cool
villain cool party for Batman to go up
against then eventually he became the
perfect gin to his yang you know yeah it
just became that yeah so I wonder how
much of that was actually planned in the
beginning or was thought out or did that
kind of just falls over the course of
time like a catamite yeah like you know
this is perfect actually I mean it does
make him super distinct in the landscape
of colorful villains for certain yeah I
like how they were talking about how
both Batman and Joker go outside of the
social norms except Batman has a respect
and understanding for the norms being a
good thing and being an okay thing that
where's the Joker this is why use
everything as a joke yeah if there's
need at all to operate outside the norm
what good is the norm anyway yes you'll
never have a 100% answer to all this
yeah this was a really cool video I
thought it was gonna be different I
thought it would be a video that's
really just hardcore exploring in a
therapeutic way who the Joker is just a
hardcore psychoanalysis of him yeah the
thing is he's such a mystery you can't
quite label it you know yeah there's a
lot of generalizing you can do and a lot
of good but broad there's a lot of
theorizing yeah yeah and again with a
character like this one in particular I
imagine it's a little hard to find a lot
of real-world counterparts to this game
yeah there was nice to see something too
of this variety that had actual experts
and little breakaway interviews and
stuff like that it's a bit different
than the format that I'm used to on
YouTube I mean I like this because it's
like Batman views Joker as if he's crazy
where as in Joker's world he views what
he's doing as the thing that kind of
should be done and so if anything Joker
might be viewing Batman as you're crazy
to think you could help the world you're
crazy to think that this world can get
any better with you in it
bad man's going you're crazy because of
how you're hurting or all do you know
it's a good philosophy battle to me I
feel like from the Joker's perspective
anyway it's almost like we're both crazy
I'm just pragmatic enough to accept my
and to accept the lack of order I see in
this world yeah what's your Excuse
where's your line buddy this video
cannot have fallen into our hands at the
perfect time working with better health
calm and then getting our tickets since
those original IMAX screenings I think
since I've seen it oh boy
alright guys well thanks for tuning in
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell and
hey if therapy online therapy is
something interested in better health
calm link in the description box give
them a look